welcome everybody good to have everyone
back here we are excited to um
get going in just a few minutes i see
people are filling into the room it's
good to have everyone here in this fine
may evening i assume it's fine
everywhere in the world no bad weather
anywhere but i know in the new york area
it is good weather so everyone is
enjoying that
so it's uh right before we get started
we'll do our normal announcements
and we just have you know the normal
stuff
first thing is jobs
if you are looking to hire someone
or you are looking to get hired
you should go to the job postings
channel of the ny hacker slack
go there post the jobs that you are
looking for in fact someone just a few
hours ago asked me about announcing jobs
and since we're not in person it's kind
of hard to announce jobs go to the job
postings channel and you'll find jobs
there i think that'll be really good for
everyone because everyone likes getting
jobs and everyone likes hiring people so
it's a win-win for everybody
um personally since i am on screen i am
hiring for my company lander analytics
we're looking for sales we're looking
for
linux uh developers and engineers we're
looking for shiny developers so please
go to landeranalytics.com careers and
find a
find a job there if you're looking for
one then as per our usual
pizza
so i got my pizza over here
i burned it i reheated it incorrectly i
made a mistake i burned it a little bit
but this was a beautiful looking slice
before i got to it you can see the bake
on the bottom
um it had good cheese lock the slice i
had earlier and since i reheated it
things went a little astray that's from
a place called antonio's
but let me know where you folks have
food from let me know where you're
coming from it's always fun to see where
different people are coming from but
also what you're eating
like everyone knows i'm a sausage pizza
this one's from antonio's and hopefully
you folks all have
um
good pizza or other food
we are very excited about
the next two months
our this month's speaker
was our very first virtual speaker he's
spoken other events we've had our
conferences our meetups but in april
2020 as we all were in lockdown noam
came on it was our very first virtual
speaker
and if all things go well
he will also be
almost exactly two years later our last
only virtual speaker
because starting next month we are going
to back to a hybrid model
in person and virtual
exact details are going to come soon but
we're going to have the in person
component somewhere in new york city
and the virtual component on zoom so if
you're coming from far away like coming
with your teriyaki chicken from boston
you'll still be able to join us with the
chat feature enabled we'll have zoom and
in person
so next month june 2nd
will be david robinson
he'll be in person we'll have the
details announced in the next couple of
days
and it'll be a great time and we'll do
both in person and virtual for those of
you there you'll be able to eat pizza
with us all together those are not there
you could have whatever food you want
from far away i'm really looking forward
to that there is going to be a rule from
the venue that everyone must be
vaccinated to get in so you're going to
need to show proof of vaccine
either your vaccine card or your
actually you might need to register the
company we'll have details a little bit
you might need to be
registered in advance of this company
system details will be coming but you
need to be vaccinated to get into this
building we are very excited about that
so more details are coming and remember
it will continue to be hybrid virtual
and in person
and david robinson our june 2nd speaker
remember that folks mark your calendar
june 2nd
starting roughly around 6 30. i think
the talkback should begin right at seven
but we'll come up with details he's
gonna be our speaker and he's also going
to be the bartender for the new york r
conference coming up a week later june
8th through 10th is the new york r
conference our first one back in person
and virtual you can do either one
it's going to be a really fun time we
have some great speakers jennifer hill
max kuhn who'll be another bartender in
addition to david robinson andrew gilman
bernardo lairs iggy skoken megan
robertson tom bliss
a lot of really fun speakers there's
going to be workshops on june 8th you
could take a machine learning workshop
you could take a causal inference
workshop a shiny workshop or even a
python for our users workshop it's going
to be all sorts of good stuff to learn
more you can go to
rstats.ai to check it out
you can get a thirty percent discount
using code ny hack r30 just remembers
that here tonight we want to welcome you
as members of this community again go to
rstats.ai and use code nyhakar30
because this conference is really meant
to be like a three day r meetup and
remember r and friends uh this whole
meetup has been for over a decade our
and friends so we really like to see a
good turnout
another thing we have
no starch press
offering the meetup group a 25 discount
on all their items
until june 5th and you can use code
irny22
all capital letters irny22
that'll get you 25
off of no starch press so that's pretty
awesome
so remember folks june 2nd david
robinson will be our first in-person
speaker in two years and it'll be both
in person and virtual june 8th through
10th will be
the new york r conference and you can
get a 30 discount with ny hacker 30 if
you go to rstats.ai
to check out all past talks of this
meetup you can go to nyhackguard.org
no starch press is giving us 25 discount
code ir ny 22 22. sorry about that folks
um if you're looking to hire or get
hired go to the job postings channel the
meetup
and enjoy your your pizza or other food
with that
i'd like to say we've come full circle
hopefully we'll see as long as
everything's go corner plan our very
first
fully virtual speaker and hopefully our
very last for a while virtual fully
virtual speaker i'd like to everyone
give a warm welcome to noam has not only
been spoke twice during this pandemic
but has also been providing the zoom
link for us this entire pandemic and we
all know how crucial that is um he's a
repeat meetup speaker repeat conference
speaker
and an excellent biker so everyone
please welcome noam with a virtual golf
clap and i will do one audibly if
everyone could do it in the chat
thank you very much jared uh
good good to be here
again now i guess it's been my fifth
fifth or something like that uh uh talk
between the the army in the art
conference fifth through sixth the
seventh and uh it's always a great group
to talk to and looking at the nt uh the
attendees it's fun that there's new
people and a bunch of people i know from
the new york army meet up but actually a
bunch of other
communities we we work with elsewhere
are up and cy and others
so
uh today i'm going to talk about data
versioning for reproducibility with our
and adult a potentially very dry subject
last time i did this when it was april
and we were in lockdown it was uh on
coronavirus research and i think we had
the large i think i don't think we've
ever had as big as a virtual audience as
as then um but i'm glad to be able to be
talking about drive topics rather than
emergency topics
um
before i
dive in let me tell you a bit about
myself so i sort of come to the
our meetup from uh perspective of two
different organizations so my background
is actually as a disease ecologist i
work in
computational disease research uh
disease discovery and forecasting i work
at an organization called ecohealth
alliance ecohealth alliance is based
right here in new york city we're an
international
non-profit focused on wildlife
conservation and human health doing both
research and advocacy
at those places where people are
interacting with wildlife and forests
and gaining the understanding and
communicating and education to help both
protect people from diseases that can
spill over from wildlife and protect
wildlife from the diseases and other
consequences of
human encroachment into wildlife habitat
i also wear another hat at an
organization called our open side our
open side is a
non is an open source nonprofit
developer collective we like to call it
it's an organization that's focused on
improving the uh interoperability of
data the the openness of science the
ability to advance science through open
source data and code and we do a lot of
activities in the r ecosystem ranging
from
peer review of our packages establishing
standards for evaluating statistical
algorithm doing community outreach to
improve the accessibility and diversity
of the our developer ecosystem
and sort of doing testing of new tools
that we think will be interesting for
reproducibility such as uh
containerization new tools for and new
tools for things like versioning and so
we're going to talk about today is
something that's both sort of in the
tool set of what i use for computational
research
and this sort of sort of frontier
scanning that we do with our open side
so the plan for today uh is to talk uh a
little bit with some background on sort
of versioning data in general why we do
it what some options there are for doing
it uh what are what sort of the types of
tools you might use and the reasons you
might use them in a broad way what we've
looked at in other places in our open
side
and then i'm going to jump into an
introduction to a tool called adults
that i and my team have been working
with for a few months which i'll
describe as a get like sql database and
i'll talk about what that means
a little bit uh i'm not a developer of
adult itself i'm a new user we have some
of the developers
here but it's a tool that i've been
experimenting with and i have an agenda
with everybody here in using this
because i am
interested in seeing
uh the our community also
try it out
because i want us to kick the tires to
see whether it's a good tool for us to
work with
and the adult's team which is very
communicative and very responsive to
their users
uh will put more effort into our users
if more our users
try it out
and so i'm hoping that some of that
two-way communication can come out of
this
uh
i'm going to introduce you to adult r
which is what i've been working on which
is an r client for the adult database
i'm going to live demo something i have
been working on it up till about
65 minutes ago
so uh you know we'll see how that live
demo goes i've just punched in a new
feature in the last hour
um i'll show you around with that and
then i'm going to talk about some
workflows that you could use it for in
the workflows that we are trying out
right now at ecohealth alliance
uh then i'll talk about things that i'm
developing the adult is developing and
for q a uh we'll be joined uh by jason
and zach who are in the audience um and
uh for uh your questions and our
questions for each other
so
the first
thing to think about is why
we would version control data at all i
would think about it sort of you know
something that is sort of an intuitive
idea for people who are like really deep
into reproducibility in a certain type
of development but trying to understand
uh what's the purpose of version control
data helps us understand what kind of
tools we might want for it
um and then for
most people it's like not the part of
the system they work with at all and so
if you're version controlling data you
want to make sure that it works for
those who don't care
um but i mean the fundamental problem is
that a lot of data is live we work with
data streams that come in that represent
the state of a system that represent new
data gather it's the new clicks at a
website or the the new swipes in my case
it's new data coming in from the field
from veterinary monitoring from
scientists uh who are collecting
collecting new data and so new
information comes in and that tracks
often real processes in life
um
and it changes over time and sometimes
data changes in predictable ways so you
can add more records you have
expectations people will change fields
in the back end of a of an app or
something like that but just as often
you have all sorts of other strange
mutations and changes to
not just the data but the structure of
the data the metadata and the database
because things go through
revision and curation the schema of your
data changes meaning sort of like what
the columns and your tables are in the
relations to each other because you have
changing goals a database can be
designed for one purpose and change to
another uh you can design it for one
purpose and discover you need something
else
often there are sort of quality
assurance and quality control processes
that cause you to go back and need a lot
of revisions one example i think of on
that front is
we have databases full of collections
from animals and those animals
have names
and as biological research continues uh
the names of species change so you might
have a bunch of categories of animals i
want to go back
and change the name of everything that
used to be called therapist gigantis
which is the flying fox is now terrapus
medius so it's not like we've collected
a bunch of different species we have to
go back and change the archival data
again so it's not something so simple as
oh we've added new records we have to go
back and do wholesale modifications
that's going to change our processes
down
and yet in the face of all of these
changes we need to be reproducible and
auditable if i do an analysis and
publish it in a scientific forum
i need to
make that analysis reproducible in such
a way that can trace it back to the
original data that it came from
but if we're connecting to a database
that's undergoing revisions like this
there needs to be some way to control
for
those constant changes and
have a record of what the state of the
data was at the point where we did our
statistical analysis or machine learning
and so that's the use case that i think
about a lot it's it's not the um the
only one
um
another big one is on the challenge of
uh collaboration in your database
development curation so you might be
building a database
for a specific purpose be it that you're
building the structure of a database
because it's the back end of some
interface or some app or you know if you
try to assemble a lot of data a bunch of
work that we do ends up being sort of
harvesting records from different sort
of historical scientific
archives databases and literature and
putting things together and that often
involves a team of people getting
together and all submitting records but
even as they submit records finding
new types of new types of records we
have to capture any types of data we
have to capture and so they have to be
able to collaborate in this elaborate
often non-linear way to have all that
information put together and for all
these reasons we need
some kind of mechanism to trace our
steps
and
build a database incrementally
so
those of us who have been involved in a
process like this probably at some point
have uh ended up uh doing uh
uh the approach of using git git is the
tool that probably the bulk of us here
used to version code
most of us are familiar with git and
github
and
git hat is a very effective version
control and collaboration system
for
code or fundamentally
groups of files organized in folders
that the files themselves are organized
as lines of text
when the information you have is
organized that way
git is designed essentially to help you
version control it and there are
probably cases where using git to serve
your data is not a bad idea if you're
doing something where you have an
analysis and a set of data
um
in a lot of cases you would sometimes
want to keep those coupled together for
purposes maybe just sort of like the the
data creation and the analysis are
really one unit and you can put that in
the same point sometimes that's bad uh
there's a lot of cases where you want to
decouple your data processes and your
code processes and you don't want things
in
the same git repository let alone
another git repository
this approach is
very inefficient for a lot of data
so because fundamentally git is
organized around code and lines of text
and data isn't necessarily
organized in that way sort of physically
or conceptually
data you know
if you have square data like tables and
csvs uh then your changes are not
necessarily two rows but they could be
two columns
lots of data is in different structures
such as json files that aren't
necessarily versioned well on that that
front so fundamentally it's sort of a
mismatch especially when it comes to
efficiency and also it's not really
aware of those data structures that are
there on the other hand there are
definitely tools that help you do this
you know it's definitely a solution for
certain cases
uh
at the at our open side we do this peer
review of code and one of the packages
that went through that is something
called get to our data that specifically
works on saving data into formats that
are maximally compatible with git
structures
so
for instance the same data could mean
different things in different order
quality different orders but git would
not see it that way so get to our data
maintains data ordering and there's a
number of other things to try to make it
as efficient as it can be
and so that's one tool if you're using
something like this you can use and then
there if you're in our user a number of
other packages that are designed for
sort of understanding
differences across the data object dif
is a general package by brody gaslam for
comparing
[Music]
uh versions of our objects you might
have stored daf is specific to our data
frame so here on the right is sort of
the kind of thing you can compare
different data frames in r and get get
like differences between them
and so
this is something that can be used and i
definitely used it within certain
limitations so
i gave you an example of when we're
trying to pull together information from
different archives we have a big study
we did a few years ago
that was
sort of a
machine learning approach to
understanding
the viruses that could be in certain
different types of mammal species and it
required really diving into long
historical
uh archives and
uh literature to understand what people
had found in various expeditions over
the years and that was something where
we built a database collaborative with a
bunch of people through git
and github
you know these these csv files have long
commit logs where we're like oh gotta we
gotta fix this reference we gotta change
this so it turns out this was in the
wild and not the domestic animals so we
have lots of commit logs like this and
and changes like this but fundamentally
one of the challenges here is what
you're what you're doing is you're
you're versioning the data format you're
versioning the file you're not
versioning the data itself that it's
representing
and when your data is on this form it's
not preserving the data types it's not
preserving the interrelationships
that more rich
database technologies can give you
then there's this whole other class of
versioning approaches that i'm calling
here versioning in a build system uh so
there are
a number of different tools that uh
our users and especially people who are
building machine learning pipelines of
various sorts might use
that are fundamentally build systems
that are around tracking the different
objects required to produce a final
output
so
these are often
directed acyclic graph setups
essentially that take in the combination
of your code and your data and run
everything through a series of steps
and often what they're doing is they're
building efficiency around the caching
of the intermediate objects that you
build
so
uh the r package targets is probably the
latest and greatest package in the r
ecosystem specifically for this
and it has versioning capabilities so it
doesn't just cache the objects that you
store
but it has the capability to do
versioning around those objects that you
store
essentially so you can back up to a
previous version of your code and a
previous version of your objects and run
again and underneath it it can use git
um it can also use the amazon s3 storage
system and its versioning approaches
to do things as well
outside of the r ecosystem there are
more general tools there's one called
dvc which means data version control
uh that sort of fundamentally uses this
approach
and there's another one called pachyderm
that does something similar it's also
built around containerizing each of your
machine learning steps
so
it's this sort of like tightly coupled
data versioning
data pipelining
build system approach
but this is generally not data aware at
all so what happens across most of these
tools is that any input like a file of
data be it a parquet file or a csv file
or a connection to a database that you
are inputting
is just stored as a binary blob an
object it's nothing more than it's like
version it's time stamp a hash file of
the whole thing and those are stored in
some kind of
key value table so that the system can
look them up and you can back up to a
different version but the system is not
really aware of anything underneath it
and that's good on one hand because it
means that you can throw any data object
or a file at it usually it's file based
on the other hand it doesn't have all of
these things that we're accustomed to
and get
such as forking and branching and having
a collaborative workflow
that lets you fork and experiment
essentially and then modify the data
itself through those tools
and then you have databases
that have versioning awareness built
into them
and
i can they're sort of a couple of
classes of these one of them are
traditional databases
of the sort like
postgres and mysql
or even the simplest ones such as sqlite
ductdb which is really popular in the r
ecosystem at the moment
[Music]
and
what you can do with those
is create
database structures internal of them
that put versioning as part of the
record so
postgres and mysql have a feature called
temporal tables and it's basically if
you have a table of data you create a
side table of data and in that side
table of data it has a record of
this is the version of that record in
the other table this is when it started
being valid this is when it ended being
valid
and in a certain situations when you
have like a really you know tightly
controlled fixed data schema right that
you know what you're setting up and you
know that like the temporal table that
you might attach to it those are pretty
useful
uh but they themselves are not sort of
versions databases
so when it comes to version databases
there's two that i know of uh that are
sort of
databases of the sort like your postgres
or your mysqls but also your uh
nosql databases like mongodb
the first is called terminusdb and
terminsdb is a graph database so it's
much more like a mongodb sort of a
document based store and it has get-like
version versioning and then there's the
one that i'm going to dive into a little
more uh which is dalt and so
dalt has
git like versioning
but it itself is an sql or relational
database of the sort that many of us are
familiar with
such as postgres or mysql or
or sqlite or even some of the things
that uh which are bigger systems like uh
google bigquery
so let me give you dalt in a in a little
bit of a nutshell it's a relational
database or an sql database so a lot of
familiar with that as a database source
it has git like versioning
dalt itself is a
single binary program so it's a program
that you can download you can run on
your machine you can run it on a server
it's written as in go
it's compiled into a single object and
that's often very useful it's much
easier to manage and install
than some other things like uh mysql or
postgres which has sort of many more
sort of system components that you have
to deal with
uh go
uh don't stores all of its data on disk
in sort of a version back-end structure
which is called noms but that's not
really important
and then the uh
interface to dolt is basically a drop-in
compatible version
um
with
mysql and mysql has a drop-in compatible
version called mariadb
that's more more open source in its
licensing than mysql so mysql maria and
dalt
are
all
compatible
in interface you know pull it hadley
here and edit my slide as i as i as i
present it
um and then don't itself you can work
within the command line or you can work
with in a
a server client
interface as you would connect to any
other database connection sort of in the
r ecosystem
so what do i mean when dalt is git like
uh and has git like versioning what are
the sort of properties
that may get what it is that that that
gold
absorbs so
the first is sort of the the general
day-to-day workflow of it so you've got
uh you can make a change to the database
you can add or stage that change then
you can commit that change and that sort
of creates a fixed point within within
your database
and then from those fixed points you can
branch you can create multiple branches
you can have you can look at differences
between those branches or between
different steps and you can merge
them together
like git it has a push pull workflow
where one can have a local copy of the
database there can be a remote copy of
the database in another location and you
can push up and pull down and this is
not necessarily centralized one can have
multiple remotes one can push the
database to different places uh but it's
often in one sort of like big central
hub where most of it comes
and then at that hub they're sort of uh
you can send patches or do a pull
request approach so people who are
looking at working on different versions
of the database can send changes to each
other across repositories that are not
necessary the same ones
uh
dalt
has a web interface much like git has
github
dalt
is run by a company called dolthub that
manages that hub called hub and also has
something called dot lab which is a
self-hosted version
of that
dult hub is that central hosting service
for adult repositories it serve it can
be a place where you push your data to
you serve your data you distribute your
data to others
it serves that data
via sort of the adult interface but also
conserve it via an api or sort of via
straight data exports
it has some limited web-based editing
capabilities and as i said you can have
a self-hosted version of it in addition
to um
a version that's uh hosted in the cloud
by the hub itself
so i think before
i get through too many bullets what i
just do is give you and show you what
dalt hub is from sort of the perspective
of
a user adulthub
is really you know uh
it's a cousin to it's or you know in a
in the best way a
knock off of github in that it's
fundamentally organized the same way
people you have a repository for your
database as opposed to your code base
and within that repository you have a
front page with a readme a database
page that shows you all of the tables in
that database
a
commit log of the changes in that
database you can have tags or releases
issues where someone uh files an issue
associated with your database poll
requests for modifications of that
database as well
when you're in adulthood database you
can uh you know view
any of the tables which is essentially
doing a query at the top of that table
and then
any table that you have you can look at
it in any point in
the
in the history the changes that occur in
the database in the history
uh and then you can export a query via
a api call
you can also
export it
just as
query results as raw csvs or a whole
table
as raw csvs this thing the csv part i
think is really essential because uh it
makes it so if you are an adult user and
you are pushing pulling two adults that
doesn't mean that a non-adult user
doesn't have access to your data if you
push things up there
anybody who is interested in your data
can get it via these csv export links
and
as opposed to trying to
run dalton clone it themselves
that said you can have other adult users
who are using it because they want to
patch or contribute or otherwise use
your data in a database form so you can
get an export of any table you're
viewing you can also
get an export at
any
commit
in your
table's history
or any branch or the tip of any branch
that you're working on so you can jump
to a
different branch and then you can export
from
that branch or that branch's history as
well
a couple of notes before i dive into the
r side and sort of give a live demo of
how this works about what dolt is not uh
and maybe
the developers will contradict me in
this and they'll have different opinions
on it but one of the things is dult is
not is it's probably not your fastest
option for data import or export so
a lot of the our ecosystem often is
interested in the shootouts between the
feather and parquet and arrow and the
speed of the various sort of csv imports
duck db is this super high performance
light database that we've been using
a lot in the r ecosystem dult isn't
going necessarily to winner those
competitions because it has a
performance overhead associated with all
of that that versioning
in my experience those those aren't
where my biggest bottlenecks are but
since don't is built off of these
traditional sql databases uh sort of
an organization like mysql it's a row
based as opposed to column based and so
you know in recent years column based
has become really interesting for people
who are doing machine learning and big
analytics because often what you're
doing is fetching the entirety of one
big column because then you're doing a
computation on that
as opposed to filtering to some small
subset of rows
so there are limitations on that side
not limitations that have been a problem
for me and similarly it's not a big data
product in the sense that it's not
fundamentally something
like spark or otherwise that's designed
to
work with data across a big distributed
uh cloud because you have enormous
amounts of data that you are are crying
down that don't fit on a single server
it's a it's a
you know a
product database
you know it has you know a lot of
capacity has a lot of speed but it's not
that
uh it's also not like your critical
system database yet uh i know that don't
back end is being rewritten quite a bit
at the moment uh you know it's still
i think would be described as uh as a
beta product though increasingly parts
of it are stabilizing i know that
uh dalt
uh the company
just recently switched to using dolt
itself as their own back end for their
own
uh for their own databases you know so
as they were building it up they had a
different database i think a postgres
database that ran their systems you know
now adult database actually runs runs
the the systems that build and run
adults themselves but there are things
changing and changing very rapidly
within the system so
uh it's more a place for uh you know
looking at your next approach your next
production system than like your your
stable critical system right now
so
how does an r user get into this or use
this in a reasonable way
so i've put together a package called
dolt r and we're going to jump into
demoing that in a moment and so don't r
is four things currently at once because
don't itself is multifaceted and so
uh doltar has to sort of draw from
different approaches in order to deal
with it so in the r ecosystem
there's a
thing called dbi the database interface
and it's the common approach
for
database interfaces into r so doltar is
a dbi style wrapper for the adult
database it lets you interface with
build database the way you would with
those other databases
it's also a manager for the adult server
so
delta is this single binary that can run
on your computer or a server if you are
running it on your own computer for the
purposes of working on a database
locally doltar can take care of that
part for you it starts it it stops it it
deals with it all in the background so
you never really have to deal with the
server process
then
doltar has an api for the version
control
parts of adults
so r has two main packages that people
use for
working directly with uh the git library
for purposes of managing version control
one is called gert uh bayern ohms uh
part of the arc and psi group one is get
to r they're very similar uh uh they
have some slight differences in terms
like performance and stability on
certain sides but they cover the same
thing so they have a
sort of a standard interface and dalton
tries to imitate that interface for
versioning
in general so you can work with
versioning in a way that feels a lot
like git
much like the adults command line
interface feels a lot like it and then
finally doltr is an rstudio plug-in so
you can handle a lot of these things and
get a lot of information from the
graphical user interface as well as the
r console
i think the best way to actually explain
all of this is to
give you a demo as to
adult r which will give you an
introduction and understanding of the
database itself
so this script which i just finished
writing i will push up and have a
repository for people to use it's also
pretty much based on the vignette that
i've written for the doltar package
which is
available
uh at this and will be on my slides and
along with the
talk materials and the talk video when
we post those
later
so
adult r package
is something we load as anything else
and
then
we might want to work with a database
that exists so before
i showed you on daltub
a
database repository this one is one i've
made specifically for demonstration and
it's the new york city flight data which
many people are familiar with because
it's the
a big example data set that's used for
deep wire and deep plier database
interfaces
so
if we were on
adult clone
uh it will pull that repository from
dult hub here of course dual hub is the
default remote
for that package so you don't have to
put the whole url but ultimately you
could change the remote
that you are pointing to
and when you do that it's going to
create a directory
here called nyc flights which is your
adult repository
inside that there is a readme that's
associated with the build repository
there's also the dot dot the hidden
directory that's where sort of all the
binary structures
so as well as configuration
of the database
live
what i've done in adult r is create the
concept of a default database so the
challenge is that both git which is
probably how you've organized your
project directory and adults
have
the same idea that they work within a
working directory on your machine and
you're not going to be into working
directories at once
but in my experience for most projects
you have the project code directory
which is what our studio is in right now
which is this rstudio project
and then you have the main database
you're working with or i think the
default database so
the way this is set up is if you sent an
environment variable
uh in which case in this case setting it
as adults directory is nyc flights that
will be the default directory and when
you run adult commands and dots are
it'll always point to that database i
find that a pretty convenient way to set
this up i'd be interested in feedback on
that
on that approach
if i
set that environment variable
then
this command which is just dalt
will always be a connection to that
database and the idea behind don'ts is
it's the
the shortest and simplest command to
handle a whole lot of things at once
when you run this command
it finds that directory if there needs
to be a database server to serve that
directory it will find the adult binary
it will start the server it will keep it
running in the background it will
reconnect to it if it needs it if that
server crashes or halts
it will restart it
ultimately the idea is that you don't
have to deal with the server processes
very much at all
so if you run adult
it gives you a connection
in this case
the connection
has a nice
print method down here which tells you
this is adult connection on my local
machine
it's called nyc flights it's being
served out of this directory and the
server process
is this pid
we're connected to it via
via this connection
we're on a branch
there's a last commit
that
was made and our working database is
clean just like in git you have no
changes to your database so you're
working directory and
is clean here you're working database is
clean
adult has a remote so you can list your
adult remotes it'll give you a tibble of
the
the name of your remote and where it's
pointing to
and with that you can interface with
this like
any other sql database you work with in
r so if
you load the dbi
database for database methods
you can
list your tables and adults
you can
read the table in dull so here we can
read this airlines table
and
if you want to you can use the dplyr
interface that many of us are used to
and it's sort of domain specific
language for working with data to work
with this database as well so if you
load dplyr and the database pyroblack in
you can define a table that
is from this database that
that calls flights and you can do your
filtering or your modification and
ultimately
collect the out the output in sort of a
standard pipeline
and finally you can you know use your
dbi package to
modify
the database you can add
add a table to this database
so when you modify it you start getting
into that sort of versioning space and
all of these adult underscore functions
deal with that so we've modified this
database we can look at what
the status is
you're on adult status you're going to
get the
current status of your database this
says
you're on a working branch of your
database there's a new table called mt
cars
this prints nicely but it actually is
printing a comes out as a data frame so
you can deal with that status and
manipulate it and work with it because
it comes out as data itself
so it's a data frame of what's the table
has changed is it staged into the
repository what's its current status
most of these commands also pull out uh
the versioning information as data so
you can run
dual log and that'll give you the
history of commits from your database on
a current branch either each of those
commits as it might be familiar from git
has a hash
you can say see who committed it
what's their email
when that commit had
happened and what the commit message is
and if you want to work from data
anywhere in that history you can check
out commits with adult use so this is
the equivalent of an sql
use command which would be go to a
specific database in this case it means
go to a specific commit
so this changes our adult status
and
that
is reflected when we print the database
now it says
using a fixed read-only database
at this commit so this is the equivalent
of being in uh what you call a detached
head state or something like that in git
you're going back to a commit so you're
not going to make changes to that there
you're not you're in a read-only mode
but you could do a checkout and launch a
new branch from here for instance
you can go back to head with a simple
adult use
that
brings us back to our
main branch
and we get have
all of our tables including the one that
we had just added
you can also make use of this as of
syntax this as of syntax is something
that's built into adults sql syntax
which i'll point to in a bit but uh as
of can take either a commit hash or a
date so you can ask what's the status of
you know give me the flight the flight
table read it out
as it was as of this date or as if a
commit
or we can now take that and
make the changes that we want so we
already did this
we already
put this new table in if i do don't add
mt cars
it's now no longer in the working set
but it is a
staged
table
if you look that once again as data it's
the same as it was before
we have the table in this case it is
staged
and then we can commit in this case you
can
uh you can commit your repository and
commit to your repository with a message
uh but i'll skip that because
we also have a setup that
if you don't create a message and you're
in an interactive session uh you'll be
prompted for one so
this works in our studio it also works
outside of our studio if you're in the
command line uh for r it'll ask for a
message so we are
adding the empty cars
table
now we have a
a clean status and you can
grab the last commit
and finally
you can
push that
to dalton
and if we go to our
dealt up repository
commit log
this needs a refresh
we've just added a table to our database
and that can be
viewed as a diff
in our data
visual tells us what's
what's changed here
and you can see not only that we've
added data
but we have changed the schema of the
database
by adding this new table to it
so this essentially is the summary of
the the minimum sql code required to
modify the database
in order
to get that
change
now
this is all
in the command line and many of us are
are rather in the the r line and many of
us
work there
but one of the really neat things about
our studio is that it has this it has
this you know
pretty functional git client
right here
which
lets you do your staging of your files
and your commits and see our history all
through here
so i wanted to see if we could get
a similar set of capabilities
in our studio because i learned to get
this pain before i learned in the
command line it sort of got me where i
needed to need it to be for that
so
uh i thought for someone to learn how to
use don't they want to be able to learn
the concepts without necessarily having
to learn all of the syntax
so
if i run dolt pane
we fire up
an rstudio connections pane
for the database now you may be familiar
with the rstudio connections pane
uh
it lets you connect to any number of
different databases have them uh connect
to them directly view the tables but
this one has some tweaks to it that are
specific to adults so first of all
the pain will always give you the
current status of the database itself up
here at the top
so you've got your main branch you've
got your last commit and that your
working database is clean
you've got where that database is stored
or if you're connecting it remotely what
the url you're connecting to remotely
is
and then you can browse your database
as you would
other sql databases so you can look at
the
schema of any table
or get
a preview
of any table up here
but what we have in addition to your
core data
is your adult system tables and your
adult system tables are where all of the
versioning information that you can use
to manipulate your database are stored
so there is a table of your
different branches of your database
there is a table of your documents so
there's a table of the readme or the
license files is stored as another
table
you have your
commit log
and then
every table itself
that you have in your database also has
a diff table and a history table
so your history table
gives you
it's sort of like a blame view uh it
gives you the
commit hash and the committer and date
that are responsible for every row
in your database so you can look this is
a row in my airlines database it was
created in this hash created by me
and
other rows were committed at other
hashes and this goes through all of the
history so even if there's if the same
row is repeated
uh repeatedly added you see which
commits so you could can pull this
and you can filter it to find where in
history certain records came from
what history you want to back up to
there is also a diff table
for
everyone
and that has columns that are to
and from
every record you have
in the table
and it'll tell you
what the change was between this commit
and this commit
in the history of your table so you can
filter by the commits and get the
differences you want and so
this was the state of the database
before
which did not have this table and then
this commit
changed this from being a blank because
there was an absence of values in that
table
to having these values for carrier and
name
so
this is a useful table for
querying and interrogating the history
of your adult database
also within this pane
we have
uh just some buttons that imitate the
same buttons you have in your
git
uh
pane here so for instance
if i were to
let's see
make a modification here so let's
add more information to the mt cars
table right
this pane updates and now
this is the last commit but the state
the working state of the database is the
mt cars table has been modified
so
you can
stage those changes
and that's staged or you can unstage
them
back to your working state
if you stage
you can commit and as before
add more data to empty cars
and make a commit to this
uh
and
you can push that
to
your
get uh your adulthub remote um and that
sends it uh uh sends it to your remote
finally there's a
uh a log and that just pulls your
adult's
log history
out
as well that's the same as the
uh
adult history table
the adult log table
down here
and the other thing that i want to make
sure it's important to note is that
there are good ways in and out of the
database
itself and the adult ecosystem so i'm
not necessarily
going to use dalt with certain
collaborators that aren't using it and
so you want to make sure that things are
possible for them to do
so
you know you could just read data
straight from donald hub dult hub has a
csv export for every
databases every table
at every commit
so i could read
csvs from two different commits
in a database
and then use a different set of tools
like daf
to
look at the differences
between
those versions
daf has this nice
html widget that shows you
changes in a table
or if you're working with the data
locally you can
uh get it into a different format for
other work so the doltz dump
function will
export into csv
json will do a full sql dump that's
capable for migrate migrating to another
database uh and also we'll export
parquet files so you can run dual dump
and
all of my tables are you're in parquet
ready for whatever wants to slurp those
up
there's one sort of thing that i note as
i i work on this uh in terms of how
people use sql databases they're sort of
there's two main uses i tend to see in
the our ecosystem um
most our users are downstream from the
data development process uh
not necessarily in all of their work but
in what they use are for their work so
there might be
an organization's main database that you
connect to and your job as a data
scientist is to like pull some data down
and analyze it
so
it's pretty common for people to be in
this and
that's pretty straightforward the other
thing that people sometimes use sql
databases for in the r ecosystem as as
storage or caching
for data packages we're distributing
data or shiny apps where you're running
something against a database
but all of these tend to coalesce around
sort of sql reading more than a writing
and so
one of the things is that the sql
reading
interfaces and tool set are really well
developed if you're a deep fire user it
doesn't matter what your data back back
end is you can
use all the verbs you're used to of
filtering and mutating and selecting and
manipulating uh and it's really well
developed
writing into an sql database is actually
a lot less well supported or has had a
lot less development for like great
ergonomic rapid interaction so
there's the dvi package and you can
write a whole table or drop a whole
table for that
there's something called the dbx package
which doltar actually uses internally
because it has some important
efficiencies for adults that lets you
better insert or upsert meaning you can
insert a record that will update a
record if it change uh if it has the
same key
and the development version of db plier
is beginning to
incorporate this and have verbs and
functions for
uh inserting data and appending data and
updating and patching things in a way
that would be familiar to sql users but
hasn't been really the case for our
users working with sql databases
so i think this is an area for
development within doltr and elsewhere
to make that sort of how are we
depositing data how are we changing data
something more straightforward and
intuitive
i want to talk about a couple of real
world workflows for this and what we're
doing with this
on my team so we've been experimenting
with it for like three or four months
now uh has been development um there
have been a lot of changes even to
adults in that time and so we've been uh
fortunate to actually have the team be
really helpful and make some changes
that we requested
but the core one which is probably
important for a lot of people here is
machine learning application and doing
machine learning on a moving target of
data so
we have one project that does global
veterinary disease forecasting and it
scrapes data from a bunch of veterinary
disease monitoring organizations and
that data updates over time
but those organizations have all sorts
of different schema and they change over
time so we can't necessarily count on
everything working the same day-to-day
and we always have to update our
scrapers often changing the schema of
the database itself
so we have a database in dalt and it's
updated
weekly by a job that we run and on
github actions and so that github
actions thing will pull down a database
and update the versions of that data and
if something goes wrong we can fork the
adults database make changes to the
schema and the structure as well as the
scraper logic
and then we merge that back in and
that's how we can sort of keep this
chugging along
in the meantime we're developing these
forecasting models and uh so the way we
develop those forecasting models is we
have a model building pipeline but that
model building pipeline always kicks off
from a fixed hash in the adult system so
if the database is updated
the main sort of model development repo
they're working on doesn't do anything
it sticks with the same set of data and
so we're developing that in a github
repo
right against that fixed hash
but the thing we are now sort of adding
for this last stage is then there's also
a continuous integration check that runs
it against the latest data so
you don't have the problem of constant
changes to data as you're trying to
optimize your model building process but
we run a check to make sure that as new
data comes in
it still works
and i just want to comment uh my two
colleagues emma mendelson and nathan
lehmann who are sort of the leads for
this project
emma doing a lot of sort of that um sort
of devops engineering on the side and
nathan building the the core of the
machine learning approach
the other workflow they're developing is
for all of our field and lab projects
the bulk of the work at ecohealth
alliance is people
in the forest trapping animals taking
samples interviewing people doing
medical anthropology
doing clinical work at different places
around the world so we've increasingly
been able to move to digital systems for
that data collection so lots of
tablet-based data collection where it's
not tablet-based data collection people
are entering things into a sort of a
live a live live web storage as opposed
to things on their own machine and so
they enter they do that using a couple
of tools one called open data kit one
called air table that you might be
familiar with
and what we're trying to build from this
is a system where we take those in and
those continuously populate adults
database that updates over time as the
field teams change but
that database also has schema changes as
we discover new things that we have to
record often a field database
program changes over time because new
goals are added say to the survey work
we're going to work with more species
we're going to do new tests we're going
to move from
pcr based viral detection to
serology to detect viral antibodies so
we need new fields we're structuring
something differently maybe those
species changes happen so
that database has to change over time
but that database is also
the base against which our scientific
publications happen so
researchers who are doing work
off that database will be writing code
to run
models from simple regressions to sort
of complex phylogenetic modeling
essentially
and they don't want to work with a
moving target
and we're sort of separating them from
the adult workflow by saying well if
there's a csv export for everything on
adulthub
we start running our analyses with that
so
run your analysis
you know from this url you pull down
this uh this csv from this hash and you
can do your analysis and if you want to
update you can just update to the new
branch tip and when we get to the point
of scientific publication and getting
things out when we need sort of a whole
package where everything is reproducible
we can tag both our code
and our data to create a release and
both together get our and both can be
archived and linked to each other
and that sort of separates the adult
process which is going to be much less
familiar to most
essentially because we just have sort of
csv as the interchange between our live
data process
and the analysis and scientific
archiving
so there's a few things that i'm
planning to do with doltar itself um i
want a better interface to the adult hub
api as that's being developed and just
to be able to query against the website
the way you can query against local
database
it should be able to support spatial
data soon that's more of a mysql issue
dalt and mysql both have native spatial
formats uh but the r spatial ecosystem
hasn't quite caught up to having methods
to deal with that deal with them so
it's pretty straightforward to put that
together and that's something you can
have so you can store your shape files
essentially in your adult database
um dalt has new versioning functions so
adult r needs to wrap those and support
them
and then i want to think about some of
those database writing economics you
know like there's not a straightforward
way that's like just add this column to
the table in the database or just add
this data that may include new columns
database and we are doing some of that
in our sort of like in our core
workflows and that will end up migrating
to doltar the doltar open source package
as well
and of course if you're interested in
trying out and want to file issues just
go to our github repository and say what
you're interested in
there's also a lot of stuff to come in
dalt itself
it's a very fast moving company with a
very fast moving development
all of these things that showed up uh in
the past couple of years all of these
things that are showing up this year
a whole bunch of other things that are
not scheduled a bunch of other things
that were put in that were not
necessarily in the roadmap which is
which is linked here because uh you know
users uh like myself but other people
came in and requested things and they're
they're very responsive so
uh if there's something that's a you
know sort of an essential feature to
your your workflow it might be something
that can
uh come in and we'll have uh
zach and jason talking about uh that and
you can ask them questions in just a
minute
so
that's it for me uh i'm eager to uh hear
your questions uh about doltar and dalt
and talk with the developers that will
invite on everyone a virtual clap for
gnome for that excellent talk uh noam
has given uh like i said many talks over
the years and each have been about
different topics completely we added
about uh redoc we've had about corona it
was about gams about
data versioning uh we've had so many
different types of talk to know them
it's really cool seeing all these
different talks everyone please you know
have a nice
uh that nice uh virtual applause
but let's go ahead and do a q a me
introduce
zach musgrave
and
jason fulgum
welcome folks everyone a big round of
applause for uh people joining in the
middle
all right
so
zach and jason are developers at dalton
uh
who uh i've worked with in the past
couple of months as i've uh gotten to
know uh their product uh
uh i'm i don't work for them and i'm not
paid to endorse them uh and i'm happy to
to critique uh critique don't from the
perspective of uh of
uh
and our user and developer but uh it's
really been a pleasure working with uh
with the adult team they're really
they're really responsive and interested
in the use cases that people might be
putting their work to so
uh we're eager to hear your questions
before i guess we get questions from
anyone else i'll
uh i guess i'll have a question for uh
jason and zach
uh what do you think people should know
about uh about dalt and adulthub that i
didn't cover
good question i think
the biggest one for me hopefully you can
hear me hopefully audio is working
um
wanted to point out one of the new
features we launched actually just
yesterday
so we've been doing a lot of work to
make dual better add a lot of features
you mentioned those
one that we just launched this week that
we're really excited about is host adult
so we heard from a lot of customers that
they want to use dalt but they don't
want to run their own database
so just uh that's the number one thing i
would mention is that now there's a way
to use dolt and have us manage and run
it for you and uh you can just use it
all you want uh through the web ui
the other thing i would add
i think that gnome touched on this
during his talk as well is that uh
performance has has not been our biggest
concern up until now
but we are in the middle of a rewrite
with where we're we're seeing anywhere
from you know four to ten times uh speed
gains depending on what kind of uh
reader right we're talking about uh so
it is getting faster we have to be as
fast as my sequel kind of by the end of
the year um that's kind of our i don't
think we're going to be as fast as as
some of the csd tools that people in the
ml ops space are used to using but it'll
definitely be as fast as a traditional
database like mysql or radio
um jason you mentioned
don't host it is that different than
adult hub that noam was showing earlier
yeah that's right yeah so we've had
dalton around for a while it's uh it's
really the analog of github just like no
mentioned um so you can go there you can
access your databases you can
collaborate um but you don't necessarily
get a uh just direct sql connection like
you do with a traditional database and
we heard a lot of people asking for that
they want that sql interface
for oltp workflows
which is different than what we provide
through doltop so if you're writing an
application and you wanted to have that
traditional database access like
connecting with a mysql client to a
mysql database that's exactly what
hosted dolt is
so really excited about that i'll post
in a link to our announcement blog as
well
yeah i think i think for this audience
adult hubs is probably the more relevant
place uh it could like asian said it
really is a direct analog to github it's
kind of for this offline collaboration
so you're not using dolt as a live
database that you're going to hook up to
an application using it to share data
and collaborate with others if you do
want built to power an application then
that's when you'd want it to be posted
or you just don't want to deal with
yourself
well you don't have to deal with
yourself on on dull health either it's
just you can't you can't connect to it
with your bicycle client right okay
and that actually brings me up to a
question i had no i please want you to
ask a lot of these but this i just
brought to it when you did dole clone
gnome does that pull down the entire
database from dot hub to your local
database what's going on there yes
that's it's it's sort of much like when
you do a git clone right uh you are
pulling down not just the files at the
tip of the branch but the whole history
um and so
uh dult clone does the same you're
pulling down the entire database
including all the
the version history so it's going to be
larger than just the tip but there's the
efficiency of the storage it's not like
you have uh every version that's there
um
i don't think there is a shallow clone
capability you can clone into a new
database in a sense that like you can
create something fresh from the
from the tip if i recall and i might
even be able to do that table by table
but there's no sort of shallow clone of
the source
that you have with git clone
that's not quite true there are some
kind of hacky ways to to get a shallow
clone they're not well supported so we
don't talk about them very much but this
we know this is something people have
asked for so we're working on ways to
kind of expose these and make them make
them better um
we also kind of envision a future where
most people when they run a clone if
it's on a large database you're not
going to be pulling down every single
byte from the remote store you're only
going to be pulling some subset that you
need to get started and then you'll do
a mix of reads and writes to local disk
and to remote as needed so you can kind
of run it as a
like a internet enabled application if
you want to to
and this is just to make clone lighter
weight
and noam you just sort of touched on
this question but the question is here
does storing all these diffs take up a
lot more space in just the data itself
and you touched on it but does it and
you want to dig in deeper some
quantification yeah i can i can feel
this so the
the
dolt is not delta encoded uh in a
technical sense but you can kind of
think about it in terms of its storage
costs in terms of delta encoding right
so if you and i
uh make some tables and then we make
some commits and we add rows and make
another commit the proportional cost of
that those later commits is the delta
between the two
the two versions of the table right
you're not uh this isn't quite true
there's technical details to go into but
that's the right way to think about it
so you're you're paying storage costs
proportional to the amount of things
that change between revisions and then
multiply that out for all the revisions
in the database um but it is like
getting this snapshot encoding at its at
its root um so it has a nice property
where if i make a bunch of changes and
then
undo them i'm not paying a double
storage cost for the things i undid i'm
not paying to delta encoded and then
paying twice to undealt it and code it
if i have two table snapshots that have
the same data they actually are the same
snapshot so i'm actually i don't pay any
storage penalty for storing that version
of the table twice that's a nice
property so let's say you have a table
100 rows you add a row you're now
storing that 100 first row and
a line saying that that hundred first
row is new
yeah it's i mean it's again there's
technical details and it's there there's
gonna be some some overhead for for that
but you have the right idea it's
proportional to the to the size of each
change as opposed to storing each
snapshot as a whole yep all right
and then if you have the hundred first
run you change it you're now storing the
changed one and the diff about the
change one roughly that's yeah that's
exactly right so don't don't treats uh
modify as kind of a delete and add so
for every row in the table we have uh
the the old states and the new state
it's not smart enough to kind of like if
you have really wide columns or really
wide rows with say hundreds of columns
which can happen in nl it's not
currently smart enough to if you only
change one of those columns
you're only going to change you know the
10 bytes in the storage format it's
gonna it's gonna make it an entire
another copy of that whole row um so it
is the the row is kind of the the units
of of diving in versioning in dull
okay
noah before i go through the rest of the
audience questions do you want to sort
of ask uh
no i think we should jump into into some
of the ones and even expand the ones
that were even added in the chat so
i see one from eric scott hi eric uh
eric asks if we run the adult status
what does it look like we just change a
single value in the table so i run it it
doesn't change anything different so
don't status
uh you know if you run git status right
you get the list of the files that have
changed uh and then depending on what
your
like sort of view preferences are you
might get like the number of number of
line changes or you know number number
of lines deleting or not right now don't
status in r uh and i remember this this
is the r api wrapping different parts of
the the adult internal api just will
tell you if uh the list of tables and
whether they've been modified added
deleted whether you and so whether you
add one line or at 100 lines it's going
to tell you modified um one of the
things that i'm sort of been thinking
about is like what should sort of like
the default diff view be there's there's
dult has a whole number of system tables
and increasing number of functions that
are designed to like give you a view on
diffs
right and there are different things you
want in those diffs uh including like
just the chain just the changes that are
the schema changes right like just like
what columns have been added or what
tables have been added uh as opposed to
like what value's been changed and so
probably want to have
i currently don't have like the default
here the here's the the changes which is
sort of the equivalent of like when you
go to
the diff button right in in our studio
it'll show you here's the you know you
can click on the file and here's the
green parts that have changed in the red
parts that are gone
currently in in r you don't get that and
so you have to do a slightly more
elaborate query of those diff tables to
get get the specific differences
yeah the the get tool or the the adult
tool itself um hopefully picked up on
this it works exactly like the get the
git command line so all the all the
commands that you're used to and get
they work exactly the same they take all
the same arguments the same flags
everything um so there's a there's a
don't diff command just like there's a
get diff command and that's going to
show you the the red and green plus and
minus for every row you change in the
table and it also has a
dash dash summary flag you can give it
so if you have a large set of table
chains you just want to make sure if it
you know do a sanity check on it it'll
show you how many rows have been added
how many deleted how many changed et
cetera
cool so now uh all those those git
commands can actually be very very uh
confusing a lot of them so
hopefully i'll have an easier time with
yours because i know i i have my uh go
to one of the conference speakers dan
gin he's my go to hey dan i screwed
something up how do i fix this thing
hopefully i won't screw as much stuff up
with this what's what's really cool
about that and i run into everyone has
these problems with get because gets
such a confusing tool uh when you when
you google the help for a git command
that you're confused about with but it's
the adult equivalent you can usually
take that stack overflow answer and
apply it directly to the adult command
and it works
because we've
we've taken pains to try to make it
familiar to people and to work exactly
the same because
gets confusing enough without trying to
add anything on top of it right
and a point to make is that uh i mean
the r package is a little is a little
behind the the command line client in
doing that and part of it is that it's
not quite the same one-to-one because
i'm trying to merge these two interfaces
that r has there's a standard interface
for the database and there's a standard
interface with git
and like there are places where those
begin to crash into each other and
that's where it ends up being a little
bit
different so like the checkouts end up
being a little different because in
adult there's different ways that you
can check out a branch but one of them
is
used and used in a database
command in mysql which says like which
schema to go to indulgence which commit
to go to
and it's one of those things that like
you know i've created something that's a
little different than the adult command
line because it seemed like the natural
the natural approach in the in the r
context so uh for that you just have to
you have to bug me in the in the deltar
issues
a question just came in so we do that
before we do the other ones because i
can't copy and paste out of zoom to save
it for later so since it just came in no
you want to run with this latest one
sure
i work let's see so patchcast i work in
a humanitarian setting where
administrative data is often stored in
excel often they don't have control over
the management so i have to work with
what i get even if types of columns
change
if i import new version of some table
into does dolt auto infer schema changes
as well as record changes or we better
create a new table with this new
revision
um so i'll i mean i'll start on this in
that like this is what well
auto inferences i'm actually i guess you
led to like one of the great things
about dolt is like schema changes our
core to it compared to a lot of other
versioning systems where like we're
stuck in a schema we're just changing
records right like temporal tables do
that
you know dolt is all about the schema
changes right and having efficiency
through that and that's why it works for
that's why it works for us dalt has an
import csv command um i'm you know which
is sort of the standard way to get
things in from in the command line often
again within r it's a different thing
you add a data frame
um
in r if you were to drop a table and add
and add the table actually
nathan who is on there would actually
keeps telling me because he's like this
is the efficient way to do this because
don't pretty much infers the thing if
you just drop a table and then add a new
version in that has different columns
right
and then you commit dot will pick that
up as a change to the table with these
new columns added and these types
changed and these other and you'll
probably get better type matching than
you might with a csv import because r at
least has types that match up
to uh your sql types
uh anything to add to that
i think i think that's a great summary
this is an important point is that
because dult is snapshot-based and it
does tips on snapshot uh dropping the
table and then just re-importing it from
scratch is exactly the same structurally
as
changing the table and making all the
edits and it's usually a lot easier to
just drop it and import it from scratch
in the use case you're talking about
where somebody's shipped you in a
version of the file um the only thing
i'll add is that uh
the
import csv command
does some sort of type inference for you
but it's it's kind of it's not a perfect
science it gets things wrong sometimes
especially depending on how your data is
format in excel um so for that case what
i would recommend is drop the table use
a sql
uh
create table statement to create the
whatever types you want for your columns
and then run the import command so
establish your your schema first with
sql because you might get better results
for
some sets of data than you would by
letting it infer automatically
anything down jason
uh i think just so this is such a cool
use case for adult uh it'd be awesome if
you know your data partners use dolt and
you had all the data but um just because
they don't doesn't mean that you can't
get a lot of value out of dult and we
see a lot of customers using this use
case
yeah this is that's that's an excellent
point is one of the things that we hear
from customers um with this use case is
that
i don't control this file it gets
updated out from underneath me all the
time i want to understand how it's
changing over time and so they're
they're not using adults to master the
data they're using adults to kind of
understand how this external source is
changing over time and so they can make
sense of it that's one of the best use
cases
i think maybe one more question jared we
um if you folks have time we can keep
going a little bit so we do have a few
more um over i have a few more toiled
away uh one that just came in again
we're gonna do the most recent ones
first i can't copy and paste um the gist
of it is can you add users to the
private repo like you can in github and
what is counted toward the gigabytes in
the free tier does it include the
metadata
i'll give that to you guys
yeah so
uh get so dope has basically the same
permission model as as github so you're
gonna pay
uh it's it's you don't have to pay
within the free tier um after you hit
your one gig storage limit then you get
start start getting charged fifty bucks
a month um but with those if you sign up
for private then you can add as many
other collaborators on your to your
organization as you want and they can
all uh see your data and you can you can
control who has read and write access to
which of your
databases that you host on on dolph uh
the the storage cap of one gigabyte uh
is everything so your history of your
database and everything that's ever been
in it applies to that that one gig if
that's too low
this is not the primary way that our
company makes money uh fifty dollars a
month for for adulthub is not material
to us at this point we're selling ltp
licenses and support contracts to make
money at this point um so if you if if
that's kind of untenable for you and
you're a researcher and you uh can't
handle the dollar bill just come join
our discord and talk to us we have
coupon codes that we can give out um
we're very comfortable supporting you up
to you know 10 20 times that amount as
long as we think your use case is cool
some older questions in here um how did
you decide between my sequel and
postgres why would you go with my sql
versus postcards or any other open
database actually
so
yeah
this is this is my fault um so as
everyone knows postgres is the better
database um but mysql is the more
popular database
and so when looking around our database
options we kind of decided to meet
customers where they currently live
we definitely see postgres as having
more momentum and it kind of is more
serious for people building applications
uh but especially the time we we
developed this equal uh integration with
dolph which would for we started out as
a commandment tool without any
peoplesport uh
for us the biggest thing was just was
just the amount of people using the tool
um
uh we like we like my sql i built a lot
of apps on my school myself but we're
def we're definitely in the future going
to build towards postgres at well
there's a project kind of in its infancy
that we're calling dult grass uh which
is basically just a adult flavored
version or a postgres flavored version
of adults um that's not gonna be ready
for at least a year but we do know that
people are uh that people want this um
and when that's available you'll be able
to just kind of toggle switch on host
adults to get whichever flavor of the
database you want
cool
um let's see that's
it's interesting on that because
postgres is much more popular i think in
the r tooling space yeah on a number of
fronts and so it's interesting because
there are a number of things like the
spatial data for instance where i'm like
am i going to build
the
like so the our star spatial system just
like doesn't have nice the the my sequel
uh mariadb spatial types as as part of
it like it's not it's not a huge michael
sumner is here it's one of the big
developers in that
that ecosystem it's essentially um
uh
well-known well-known binaries with
slightly different metadata than the
other well-known binaries but
like maybe i'll build out that spatial
or maybe i'll just wait for the postgres
one we have sort of
spatial as well as like how to handle
rasters as as you know uh structured
binary blobs
in that as well so i'll be interested to
see how
you know how that comes along and where
we decide to invest the you know build
the r connectors off of
oh
yeah there's some we had a few talks
about spatial um we have a few more
talks about spatial coming up so yeah
everyone everyone wants more spatial in
some way or another
yep yeah it's it's
one of the last kind of gaps in coverage
for our basic functionality with mysql
is so we recently had a support for
special types it's new as of
i think three or four months ago um the
limitation right now is you can't well
one there's like a hundred spatial
functions in my sql and we only support
you know 20 of them right now just the
ones people have asked for um and two
you can't create indexes on them which
i'm not sure if that matters for the for
the data science crowd as much as it
does for the sql application crowd um
that's that's definitely what our
customers are
bugging us for but it's
it's a challenge because indexing visual
types is different from indexing
integers there's a lot more to go into
it from what i can understand
the indexes are very important for
because it could dramatically cut down
like st intersects it can dramatically
cut down the time to compute that if
there's a spatial index
yeah that makes sense or archery
and speaking of indexes i think you
answer the question can we have indexes
in the database
yeah absolutely um i i think gnome's
probably a better position to answer how
that would impact your
uh the the r use case um i could like
for for a sql query it's definitely
gonna use indexes to make your joins
faster and to make point lookups and
range selects faster um but i think
gnome is probably more advised about how
those flights it's interesting because
this really gets that back at sort of
like where the the r analyst versus sort
of like the sort of like the whole sort
of data science ecosystem is so like
there are there are those of us some of
what i do michael's in the audience are
like you know building
uh systems that are ingesting things and
then providing
data sources for researchers right and
you know we often want to think about
okay how are we going to you know how
are we going to store how are we going
to create indexes how are we going to
make things maximally accessible
um i think for a lot of people who are
sort of on smaller projects and building
up it's not like most of us who are
doing that like we're working in the
native like i'll be writing sql to do
that essentially right and then you'll
have readers but also i think people
more people who are just like building
you know building up collaborative data
stores and stuff like that
um you know they're only doing so much
in terms of just like getting you know
like keys across the database and things
like that and uh i don't know i don't
you know this this audience changes all
the time uh uh here so um i'm not sure
but i think it's not necessarily going
to be the highest karate thing this
having the spatial index is it's just
that right we're going to distribute a
bunch of data
right having being able to do those
lookups is going to be is going to be
pretty important
um a question came in about how do you
deal with merge conflicts
you want to talk about jason
yeah
yeah so like we talked about before
there are really two main interfaces for
working with your adult databases
one of them is the sql interface and one
of them is the cli
so you can merge and you can deal with
conflicts from either of those
interfaces
if you're working with the cli it's
going to be pretty much just the same
experience as you're working with the
git cli
you're going to merge a table maybe from
another branch and then uh adult will
tell you if you have any conflicts
and then to resolve those conflicts you
can use the cli and you can select uh
your
your changes or their changes um so you
have some simple options for conflict
resolution uh j exact of course jump in
if i'm uh missing any big points uh but
that's kind of the cli experience um in
the sql experience you have a little bit
more control
so uh
for example you might start your merge
from the cli
and uh see that you have conflicts and
then go into sql because you want to do
a very fine tooth way of
resolving that conflict
um so i would say that's probably
the
the main way that people will resolve
conflicts is using the cli to do the
merge finding out what conflicts exists
and jumping into a sql interface and
just resolving the conflicts in the
table itself marking those conflicts as
resolved and then committing um so
really kind of the same workflow as
except you're uh kind of jumping into
sql to very uh directly modify the data
as part of the conflict resolution when
you say jumping into sql like yeah it's
like a select statement or an update
statement or something
exactly yep so you open uh maybe a sql
shell or your favorite sql workbench and
uh you can look at the data and see the
two versions you can see the conflicts
there's some system tables where dult
will tell you exactly where the
conflicts are and then uh you can just
work with the data however you want it
to be and when you're done just tell
adult that you've resolved the conflict
manually and that you're ready to commit
the merge
and this is a place where like you know
like the r ecosystem doesn't have this
language spelled out in its own way and
that's maybe that's the best way like
you end up dropping in and sending a sql
command through your our console which
is what you can do with like a a db
execute or a db or a db query uh
command right so unlike sort of the d
flyer stuff where
essentially like all these r commands
are translated into sql in order to
perform really complex queries that
extract data there's no real equivalent
to sort of doing to you know to mod to
modifying the data in the database and
so it'll really be i don't think we're
going to build out that whole grammar uh
for this purpose in in in doltar so it
will be sort of that dropping in but i
think having a little more so that it it
spits out the you know the
the conflict table that is generated uh
so you can see it will be something that
can
get developed in the dolph r client
yeah to elaborate a little bit on what
jason and um said the so if that when
you have a conflict in a file and get
the way it represents that is you have
these conflict markers where it shows
here's what was in the head here's
what's in yours here's what's in theirs
um and delta does something very similar
except instead of files obviously it's
tables so for every user table you have
a table named foo and that table has
conflicts after emerge there will be a
system table called foo conflicts um and
that table has
a schema that's derived from the user
table and it'll show you for each line
for each row that's in conflict uh the
base value our value and their value um
and the way you resolve these things is
by doing select and update statements
with joining with the conflicts uh where
you can get you know arbitrarily complex
because it's just sql
and then you tell you tell adult that
the conflicts are resolved by deleting
rows from that conflicts table as you
resolve them and then when the table is
empty we consider the conflicts result
resolved you told us it's just like
deleting the conflict markers in your uh
in your text file and you go ahead and
make the commit
so
selfishly is there like a vs code
version of this i know vs code you could
say accept head accept incoming do you
have something like that coming down
line uh sps code plugin
i don't think so uh at least not not
anytime soon um we do we do work if you
have vs code and that's your that's your
jam you can just kind of use the mysql
connector for that and just pretend
adult is my sequel
that's true of any database workbench
that you might have um there might be
compatibility issues we're still working
on so if you find one that doesn't work
tell us
but in general yeah just pretend that
it's my sequel and connect to it with
that and it should mostly work cool
uh two questions kim and i'm going to do
the second one
seems more relevant to what you're just
asking is do i need to know sql to use
thought hub slash doldar
so let me start on this one because sort
of the the point of adult r
to a certain extent is to make it so you
don't right there are definitely
limitations to that like the ones we
just discussed because sort of editing
data is something that
uh r supports less
in it's sort of like
it's all machinery alts machinery that
hides sql but
for a few things you don't anymore so
like one thing that i came in and i
started using dult hub and
then i like put in an issue request
immediately and i was like hey could we
have just csv exports of everything
right because uh like i wanna this seems
like a great place to put data but
everyone needs to know sql and no dolts
in order to get that data so now right
if you're using dual hub or someone else
is using adulthub and you just want to
work off the database including any
sort of time you know any commit any
branch
you can sort of read your csv straight
from dulthub
right and that's i mean that's one of
the workflows that we're setting up
that's how our researchers are going to
end up using this because they don't
need to learn that right then this uh
you know where r interfaces with sql the
dbi and the db plier packages you can
you can add a whole table you can read a
whole table you can run your
uh you know a filter and a select and a
group function in order to filter and
run to to generate and that internally
generates sql and that pulls the data
out
and
uh
i think one of the interesting things
that sort of might develop just like
even in the vignette is how you do the
versioning part of that so like so that
you're doing you're pulling your table
you're pulling it as of this commit or
you're querying the table history
using that uh domain specific language
as opposed to sql that's something you'd
be able to do right again where the real
challenge ends up being is in
editing data directly beyond the
um
appending a bunch of records
dropping and adding a table
um and a few other of those components
but i think you know it's something so
like we have a some long and weird
functions that we've written in our
internal pipelines that we want to
migrate right that do things like modify
column types for new data right like i
said like you're adding uh
this like you're you you're adding text
that is longer than the defined fixed
width of the text field it detects that
and it changes and it extends the width
of the text field to allow for news for
to allow for more data than it was
previously there so like that's
something that we have built up and
we'll put into the open source package
soon enough so the answer is
not entirely right uh there are probably
limitations and that's when you have to
dive in but that's the case working with
any of the sql databases
in our not just adult
yeah i think i think that that's
probably the right answer is ideally no
but there's a chance you're going to end
up with some depending on what you're
doing with don't you may need to learn a
little sql um
i think that the best way to discover
what the limits are is just to kind of
start playing with it yourself um dalton
will let you just upload csv files and
turn those into tables
and that's kind of a great way to start
playing with adults just to discover
what the capabilities are you can do a
lot of stuff just from the web without
having to deal with
any sql or any files or anything like
that
we do have people who use dult kind of
sql free i would say where they're
really just importing csv files
and they have a new version of it and
they scrub the table and import the new
version and make a commit because
they're again just wanting to see what
changed over time and keep that that is
the backup record um that's certainly
possible um it is a little bit limiting
and i don't like like gnome said i don't
think it's going to play that well with
if you want to use this with r but as a
command line tool you don't strictly
have to know any sql it helps but you
don't need to get started
just to give another concrete example uh
we have one customer i was talking to
where they really enjoy the kind of
spreadsheet editor view on goldhub and
they want to have their configuration
for their system version so a great fit
for dolthub or for adult diversion that
data and then they want to enable these
less technical people who
set some of those configuration values
to go through dull tub and send pull
request so they're definitely still
using dolt they're using goldhub but
they're not necessarily using sql so i
think just like zac and gnome described
them you can certainly use it without
sql but there's a lot of features in
there some of those are going to need to
be exercised through sql
all right
i know we're starting to run a little
late so i'll just get just a couple more
um can don't dump one of the functions
nobody showed earlier export
just one table even just parts of a
table
uh
now i'm trying to remember how i did
that
um
let's see uh
you got me to talk top of this now i am
my implementation just just drops uh
my implementation exports everything i
don't remember if doltz
dump in the command line gives you you
can select a table for it
right
we could i'm sure i could write in a
slightly extended version because it's
just you know it's doing no doing the
select the select function and then
and then running the export would be
fine right now it right now the r
function don't dump just dumps
everything in whatever format is is
being dropped
yeah on the on the on the command line
you can run don't dump and give it a
list of tables uh to just restrict it to
a set of the tables that you want um
if you want only parts of a table you
can run a query so you know select star
from my table where
index greater than 10. um and now put
that to the format of your choice two it
takes a bunch of format flags like csv
or json or whatever you want um
that's what we'd recommend for for that
use case
okay
um when you export a csv
is there any metadata that traces it
back to a specific commit
there is not i don't think that there is
a great way to represent that with
uh csv
that's a interesting use case though i
think there is an obscure format of csv
where you can actually put comments
yeah csvy has yellow at the top but i
think what's sort of more what i think
might be more relevant here is um
so the if you're pulling
uh a csv from adult hub just you're
grabbing the url
then you can just as easily hit adulthub
api
uh point right and so
you can there are uh api endpoints for
each of the tables
uh in your adulthub database
and uh so if you just hit the api for
your table it gives you the schema for
that table you know and then you can add
a query and you can get data from that
as well and so this part that's in my to
come is that i wanted uh to um
build out the dothub api client within
adult r one of the ideas for that is
essentially to you can use dult hub and
just query it directly
and it'll pull that down
right
and then also use that schema
information to set the types correctly
in r when you pull that data from the
api
so if that's the information you're
looking for and that and i'm pretty sure
and yeah and that j that that rest
response also gives it the
the the reference and the database it
the branch or the commit that you're
you're pulling from as well so
your the standard csv endpoint doesn't
but the the standard rest endpoint that
gives you json does
and then just two more one dollar
question one gnome question
um
on donald hub lab is it possible to
control access at the table level and i
will augment that on the row or column
level also
not yet
that's if that's something you need uh
please join our discord and and talk to
us about it um don't lab is is
0.3 right now it's so we're very early
on that on that journey um so we'd love
to hear more about your use case cool
okay and then um lastly all right i'm
sorry two we're just with this quick one
uh
no when you were doing dolt the function
don't
can you say that to an object like you
can't have any other dbi connection this
way you can say like khan gets dulled
all the information yes definitely you
run that con uh gets adult that uh that
works just fine and like there are other
there are there are standard dbi
functions in there too so there's one
called local it says connect to a any
other local directory where there's
adult database there's delta remote
connect to any other you know url or a
local host port where there's a database
you can do those as well under db db
connect
and then you can save that dot it's just
a standard dvi connection object but
what's special about the function
um is that it also is managing this like
when you run it what it actually does is
it stores that connection in an internal
cache and then so instead of
reconnecting it pulls from that
and checks its validity and if it's not
valid because the server has stopped for
some reason
um then it will reconnect right it will
restart the server if it needs to it or
find the pid of the server and
and and get it back so
you know i've just come to just using
don't for you know set that set that
environment variable and you don't have
to think about that background process
at all it's worked a lot better than i
actually thought it would initially but
yes it's helpful yeah
great
and then i did promise a known question
when they renamed the flying fox was
that because they found a bigger one no
they did not uh but it was like many of
these it was uh that they figured out
that what was previously thought as two
different species were one so
and generally that means that the one
that was uh
uh identified earlier right so like
someone called something medius and
someone calls them gigantis and
eventually i think they figured out that
the gigantic ones were really just the
same as the mediuses i'm pretty sure
that's that's what happened uh and so
maybe maybe one day it was not
it was only like a year and a half ago
um
they discovered this amazing like new
orange large orange bat in the
philippines really was surprising so
there are still perhaps bigger bats to
be found somewhere
um they're not they're not they're not
all counted yet so maybe they'll be a uh
gigantis or mega gigantis somewhere
hiding out
we can only hope
yeah
right and then we'll update all of our
tables of course yes again
all right well great thank you very much
to
nolan jason and zach hope everyone had a
great time remember that we have june
2nd we have both in-person and virtual
meetup with david robinson we have june
8th through 10th the new york r
conference both virtual and in person a
whole bunch of speakers and workshops
and you if you're here today you get a
code the code ny hack r30
remember you have your no starch
discount with code irny22
and you know go ahead and ask on our
slack we have our monthly meetup chat we
also have channels for help with r with
python for git uh i don't know if we
have a sql channel we should create one
if we don't have one
and hope to see everyone at our next
events either in person or virtually so
everyone just please a virtual applause
for zach jason gnome for this excellent
talk thank you everybody thanks guys for
joining
thank you thank you
bye-bye have a great night bye-bye